[Music]
this Hadron make pronouncing it
correctly Hadron yeah hey you drawn a
drum smash these things together okay
guess not really matters I'm not even
gonna call it the Higgs particle anymore
but I'm curious this thing that
simulates the Big Bang I read an article
and I know if it's true that you guys
when you turn this thing on and rammed
these protons into each other yeah you
weren't quite certain what was going to
happen and that there was a small
possibility that something could go very
wrong true or not true the in the
technical language that's bollocks
bollocks is what the English person
would say it's not dare you sir me and
my show it was as far as I can tell made
up by the press what it did was make
CERN famous okay
I remembered reading about it that you
guys had built this giant thing you were
gonna Ram some particles together and
there was a bit of a chance that the
black hole would form would all get
sucked into it but you're like let's see
what happens
it was worth it wasn't it yeah it was
worth it okay so you're saying that's
not true life out there in the galaxy
yes or no what do you think I think
though is but probably simple life and
and I think there's a good chance we may
find it on Mars within the next decade
or so you know all the signs that were
suggesting there's water below the
surface of Mars that the Curiosity rover
has been finding the geology should be
right
so the next missions that will go there
have a good chance a simple life meaning
single-celled microbes yeah not what
we've always been hoping for I don't
know why they always say when we find
life it'll be much simpler than us but
our fantasies have all been life that's
oh you pitiful earthlings
you know our robots can destroy you you
know there they're always billions of
years ahead of us and they have weird
heads and but no you said it's gonna be
simple yeah I we've not seen any
evidence of any alien civilizations
anywhere in the galaxy and we've looked
we've put inside this stories about
abductions etc you in our lifetime
what's more likely teleportation or time
travel we are both are they possible we
can do both we've already done
teleportation on a very simple rotation
[Applause]
the Twinkies coming back
and the royal couple is having a baby
now that's the kind of crap we're
obsessed with in our stupid culture you
said there's been a teleportation we've
teleported it's been a prediction of
quantum theory for decades and we've
done it with small particles so single
particles so the question is can it can
you do it with bigger things don't know
is the answer but it's been done with
the smallest particles is it possible
that in my lifetime instead of driving
home for a long time on the freeways of
Los Angeles and really losing my temper
several times and stopping the car in
heavy traffic and getting out with a
broom handle and hitting another car
that I will get into a cube and be like
[Music]
nothing will happen I'm just doing this
and I will be teleported into my home I
don't think you're gonna have to do that
today but no I got to I like the way
it's been done for all we know it's been
done with single particles we don't know
time travel it's been done in the sense
that you can travel into the future as
fast as you like but what about the past
where we get to warn Abraham Lincoln
into the past
your warning would I warn him
what would you don't go to the theater
[Applause]
not like err the beards not work
what are you gonna we'll play cards this
century you're not going to look right
with that beard yeah you know what first
of all this has been I hope you'll come
back because I love talking to you and
also fascinates me you used to play
keyboards in a rock band yeah and I'm
just curious like that's a lot of
people's dream of the coolest thing you
could possibly do but in a way aren't
you cooler now and science is becoming
cool isn't that true what do you think
[Applause]